ruby is with us in Miami Florida I
really welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve
I wish I was there Nashville has a foot
of snow I'm a full time on earth and my
husband is a full-time medical student
so I'm the only one working in our
family right now we have a little
situation we leased a car which you know
was just a we won't do it again but we
reduced to end early next year in
January
however by June of this year we need to
get another car because my husband is
starting rotations and we're going to
have completely opposite schedules so
we're looking at needing to buy two cars
by next year we don't have a whole lot
in savings right now cash we have about
I would say $2,000 and so we were trying
to figure out what the best way to go
about doing this with me we saw a car
that we really liked and it's about we
think we could get it for about seventy
five hundred cash so we were thinking
about taking out some money from his
student loans which we only try to get
only what we need for tuition but we
were thinking about taking out like
about seventy five hundred dollars to
get the car and then pay it off as soon
as you get like our tax refund and save
us a little bit of money by working some
overtime chips do you think that's a
good idea or no well Ruby if you've been
listening this show for more than about
ten minutes you know I tell people not
to borrow money yeah
for cars for student loans for anything
other than possibly a mortgage and pay
that off as soon as you can I don't even
like that one but so there's a lot going
on here that I would tell you not to do
certainly would tell you not to borrow
to buy the car what is your household
income right now including after
deductions and taxes everything I take
home about 3500 a month okay all right
and so it sounds like you're making
about 60,000 a year working
gross gross here and I'm pretty close
anyway do you have any 401ks or anything
like that coming out at work other than
taxes we have a pension that work
requires me to put money into you don't
have an option on that okay no all right
so here's what I would do if I were in
your shoes you said you had a tax refund
coming you're talking about now well as
soon as we file our taxes we haven't
gotten our w2's yet so I'm looking at
probably March okay why would they take
toolmarks
I'm just that's how it's been in the
past I don't know if I get him earlier
I'll try to follow them as soon as I can
oh so and you don't need a car until May
you said Rami mm-hmm so what would be
wrong with using the tax refund to buy a
car do we want to do that we just saw a
car though we like you don't have money
to buy a car now that is true yeah no
I'm not gonna go borrow on a student
loan and pay for that car over the next
you know decade while you finish up to
these schools and everything else no not
a chance no just wait no you know when
you have the money buy the car how much
is your tax refund usually get about
five thousand okay I would suggest about
a three thousand dollar car and use the
other 2000 towards the savings that you
begin to buy the next $3,000 car next
January when you turn the lease in okay
maybe you can buy maybe even buy the
seven thousand dollar car at that point
now I can tell that you're probably not
gonna do any of this but let me tell you
what the problem is the problem is if
you continue to borrow every time you
have a problem you're gonna have nothing
but financial problems the rest of your
life every time something comes up
that's a stress point the way out of it
is to borrow some idiot will loan you
money and then you will look up with a
pile of debt that you can't breathe
under and you'll feel like an idiot
because you won't breathe no matter what
you guys make you can't you can't I
don't earn your stupidity if you just
continue this process and so what Sharon
and I had to learn when we were in our
20s and went broke was that the borrower
is truly slave to the
and we had to draw a line in the sand
and say okay we don't borrow money so
now how do we solve the problem well
right now you got car fever and the only
the only antidote for car fever for the
car you've seen that you like that you
can't afford is a cold shower so go take
a cold shower get over your cold fever
and the car fever and just wait and pay
cash for a car you can afford if you
want to spend the whole five thousand on
a car in March that's fine but you got
to work towards how that you're going to
pay for the car next January when you're
back down to one car again mm-hmm and
I'd prefer you to go ahead and you know
start saving towards that let's just
keep these cars these cars are not
forever cars they're just enough to get
you guys through this really tough time
while he's in school when does he
graduate he's got two years left oh good
okay residency then that adds another
income yeah at the tunnel here this is
all guys change in two years so again
I'm not suggesting you drive a $3,000
car for the rest of your life I'm
talking about two years right and then
you can move up a little bit in pay cash
and then you of course attack the
student loans and get rid of them but no
I would never in a million years tell
you to borrow on a student loan to buy a
car there is not a case on the planet in
thirty years of doing this show that
would have caused me to tell you to do
that so hey thank you for the call I
hope I convinced you because if I didn't
I predict some pain in your future